so then there Comes A Time no doubt is
so successful you decide you want to be
an actress and did you audition for the
Brad Pit Angelina jie movie that you you
audition for that I I did I I feel like
I almost got it Mr and Mrs Smith you got
close how many auditions did you go to a
bunch and like they came to my house and
like a whole thing it was fun I did a
bunch of stuff like where I wanted to do
that and I but I think that with that
it's so it if I'm you can't do both you
know what I'm saying you have to focus
because it's very competitive and like
you need to and I just wanted to do it
but I wanted to do music was the band
pissed at you that you were thinking of
becoming an actress I mean I don't think
so yeah but you're right you know
whenever rock stars start to want to be
actors it the band up somehow it
the dynamic up right because yeah
I think because you split yourself or
something for some reason I think you
got to just concentrate on the band
right to keep it all together it just
was like I think well to to actually get
a job as an actor you'd have to do it
focused I never got a job really except
for the one you did the a movie with
Martin Scorsese yeah yeah that's that's
pretty that's pretty incredible like I
dip my toes in with Martin when you
don't get when you when you auditioned
for uh Mr and Mrs Smith and then Brad
Pit and Angelina Jolie do that movie do
you go and see it to see what she did
you did were you kind of heartbroken
because you think you would knew we knew
Brad already so and you knew Brad was
attached to that film yeah oh you did so
you would have been co-starring with
Brad Pit yep you would have had love
scenes with Brad yeah but it didn't
happen
yeah